ALARM AT THE BORDER
TREASURY DEPARTMENT
CUSTOMS AGENCY
Sit down.
Take off his handcuffs.
Where did they start with all this?
Take them and lock them up.
- I don't have anything to do with this.
- And who does?
He said that I only had to
make it look like I was his wife.
No one told me that
we were going to smuggle drugs.
- I didn't even know him.
- Don't listen to her. She's a trickster.
- If only Big Richard heard you now.
- Let's talk about Big Richard.
Be quiet, Elaine
So, you two are a couple
of Big Richard's toursits.
I'm not saying anything. I have rights.
- And you?
- Me neither.
We have enough proof
to get the both of you.
Umm...
Has Richard's influence
gone that far?
No, he has other things to do
than spend his money on stupid things
- You should tell him everything.
- And you shouldn't do it.
Everything was going fine until
I met you and your friends.
- Come on! Hit me!
- Put him the cell.
Are you thinking about talking?
- If I feel like it, sure.
- Do you know Big Richard?
That depends, Big Richard
and I are good friends.
Where does he get the drugs? How does
he deliver them?
Under the upholstery in other people's
cars.
- Who are these other people?
- Richard doesn't even know.
- Who did they have to meet?
- You don't meet them, they find you.
Ok, you're going to be spending a lot of
time alone.
Try to concentrate and
give us more answers.
- That's all.
- Over here, miss.
Even though the cargo proves it,
we still don't have enough proof.
I guess we'll have to
start all over again.
Start from the beginning, huh? We're
not going to get anything from these
- How can you say that?
- This is Madelaine Haley.
From the Los Angeles
police department.
- How are you?
She's good, without her
we wouldn't have hunted those two
And I've even had men in Mexico for
months
Richard can sense a detective
from miles a way.
Yeah, he's very shrewd when
it comes to our men.
- What about our women?
- That's not such a bad idea.
- Richard wouldn't even think of it.
- I have my notes right here.
- I've discovered something.
- A discovery?
- That Richard is addicted to women?
- Yes, that's true.
- What is Jackie Curtin working on now?
- She's not pretty enough.
Let's see, Lili would be perfect,
but she got married and left.
- And what about Judy Michaels?
- She went back to work and won't be
What about her?
- Yea
No, Richard likes
vulgar women.
But she could pass.
What are we even talking about?
Narcotics
Yeah, but we could send her
to Mexico with some other excuse
- Besides, the boss likes it.
- It could be an option.
I'll think about it. Maybe she could
get some valuable in formation.
- Do you think she can do it?
- Yeah.
During the war, she was part of
Special Services in the US.
She speaks Mexican pretty well.
- How do you spell your last name?
- H-A-L-E-Y
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Popcorn.
Four beers.
- Terrible.
- Over and over again.
- It's always the same thing.
- It's a mess.
Pass me the lipstick.
- Sure.
Her eyes were like the moonlight.
Her lips redder than wine.
And even though she told me that she
loved me,
Lips redder than wine.
I knew she would never be mine.
The more I longed for her kisses,
the more she smiled.
I knew I shouldn't wink at her.
She could dazzle me with her smile
A smile she dedicated to me for a
moment
Even though she stole my heart,
she left me with that smile
Men smile because she has
also taken their hearts.
They sing that
she stole their hearts too.
Her eyes were like the moonlight.
Her lips redder than wine.
I know she's a devil dressed as an angel.
Who crosses at the border.
Lips redder than wine.
On this road,
just past the border.
No, don't do that.
No, do what I tell you.
Ok.
It's a trick.
Do exactly what I tell you
and there won't be any problems.
Yes, it was my people
did it last night.
- Cigarettes, please.
- Ok.
- Thanks.
- Wait until we find it.
I'll talk to you later.
Got a light?
Give her a light.
- Go up to the room in case they call.
- Sure boss. I got it.
- Look what you made me do.
- Sorry. Try it again.
- Unless you're afraid of getting burnt.
- I don't care about getting burnt.
- But, where are you going?
- I have to go upstairs.
You know what?
You're not so bad.
Finish the drink.
Why don't you have another one?
For the road... with me.
Sure.
- I can't.
- Sure you can.
- I can?
- Yeah, of course.
Which...? No. Look.
Which room?
This one.
Hang in there.
Give me the keys.
- The keys?
- Yes, the keys.
Wait a second.
Just a second.
No.
You, you stay here.
There we go. No.
Wait.
I just want you to be comfortable.
No.
We're going to celebrate.
Come on, inside.
- Hey Boss.
- Stupid.
Hi.
Who's the girl?
- A friend of mine.
- Get rid of her.
- She's a friend.
- Get her out of here.
You!
- You're not going to pay attention to
him, right?
Fine.
Don't think this was all in fun.
I'll see you around.
I hope you don't think we're being rude.
No.
Come by tomorrow.
Then we won't be strangers.
You're very nice.
You'll find me even nicer
once you get to know me better.
I would really like to get you better.
- What do you want, McClan?
- You know what I want.
Did you send Harvey Gambin? How is he?
I've been trying to get a hold of him.
We could do a little business together.
Pick it up, Joe.
Come on, tell me what you want.
Harvey says you have a shipment
ready. He says he wants it.
Tell Harvey...
The only thing I'm going to tell him
is which boat it's in.
You will give the in formation, won't you?
What if we convince him? A little
dust on the arm. He'll like that.
- Sometimes, it makes the skin crawl.
- It doesn't sound bad.
- Are you trying to scare me, Johnny?
- You Richard? Never.
You're too thick skinned,
but I don't think she'll put up with it.
She doesn't know anything.
Who was going to tell her?
That's for sure. Who told
me nothing? I don't know.
- What about you, Ducey?
- She hasn't told me anything. Only he
Tie him up.
- Boss, tell him I don't know anything.
- That's true Ducey, you don't know
Why don't you tell us, Ritchie and
you'll save all this?
You'd sell your own life for
a few bucks, wouldn't you?
Maybe it's you
who'd sell it, McClan.
"It's in the port;
in the northern part."
Is it grey?
I asked you
if it's grey.
Yes.
Is it anchored in up high?
- Pretty much, like it always is, McClan.
- Good. I knew it would be there.
It works a well as
truth serum.
2, 5, 1,
Someday you're luck is
going to run out, McClan.
McClan here.
It's a boat. In the northern part.
Yeah, that's it.
I'll do it.
Harvey, I want to thank you.
Do you want to say something to
He says "you're welcome", Harvey.
See you later buddy.
I told you one of these days
you're luck was going to run out.
Wait a second.
Richard, wait.
Thanks, doll.
I want to talk to you.
- I don't know anything.
- Come on.
- Could you tell me how to get out of
here?
Yea, over there.
You, come here!
Come here!
You move faster
when you're carrying a gun.
- The boss wants to talk to you.
- He seems strong and brave.
- Sit down.
- Why did you hit me?
I had to.
Or else I wouln't have been able to bring
That's why I did it.
Want a cigarette?
How long have you been
working for Richard?
He asked you... how long have you been
with Richard?
- 5 minutes.
- You want us to believe that?
- It's true.
- Give her a second to explain.
- Have you ever made a trip for Ritchie?
- What trip?
To get the merchandise to the other side
of the border.
Boss, I think we should
get rid of her. I'll go by myself.
I don't want you to it by yourself,
Johnny.
You know, husband and wife.
Make it look respectable.
- I'll get you guys a tourist visa.
We'll see how she works.
Any woman will behave well
if the pay is good.
- Be ready to leave early tomorrow
morning.
Go on, tell him something.
How much am I going to make from this?
See. She knows what she wants...
- Miguel!
- What?
Go the hotel, pay the lady's bill
and get her luggage. What's your
- Clarice La Rue.
- What?
- Clarice La Rue, sir.
- Good morning, Don Pancho.
- Good morning.
Make sure you're there Friday,
at noon, at the Los Angeles Zoo.
OK.
But I still don't know who
I'm supposed to meet there.
You'll find out when you get there.
Noon, in front of the monkey
cage. Got it?
- Got it. Get in the car.
- Got it.
- Let's go Miguel.
- Yes sir.
Miguel, you're in charge of these two
make sure they get through the border
Yes, sir.
Casa Hermosa is the best hotel.
The rooms have bathrooms and hot
- What town is this?
- Hidalgo. We're going to sleep here.
Move it.
Wait.
- Do you know what this is?
- Of course.
Put it on. It's part of the tourist pass.
Put it on. It part of the job.
Congratulations!
Yeah, man!
- Good afternoon.
- Do you have any rooms available?
Yes, they're all available.
Welcome to Casa Hermosa.
We always try to treat
the Americans the best we can.
Give us a room facing the street.
OK. Mr. And Mrs. Smith.
This way.
- Can you bring us the luggage?
- Of course. Bye.
- Are you looking for someone?
- No. Just the police, the feds.
Or the town security, or an
assailant, or Richard's guys.
Don't you think we should've
got two rooms?
- Why?
- To be safe.
Safe from what?
Let's get this straight
I'm not going to...
Relax.
How do you expect to enjoy your
honeymoon if you can't relax?
I just want you to know. This
is strictly out of convience.
Right.
We are strictly married.
Miguel!
- That's great music.
- Where can we get some food around
- Who is it?
- Felipe!
Come in.
- Where should I put them?
Over there, on the chair.
Good.
I hope you're happy.
Only the best for the Americans.
Thanks.
Now you know why
Miguel is such a great guide.
- Should we eat?
- Yes, let 's go.
Lock it.
Be quiet!
Tell Mary we'll be at
the hotel at the border on Thursday.
With the narcotics load.
Joe and Ritchie McEvoy's girl.
Arrive Thursday at border with narcotics
load and Ritchie's girl.
Hi, Juanito?
I just bought some food.
Sausage, cheese, ham a little bit of
everything.
- Did you get yourself something?
- Yeah, this and this.
- A telegram for your loved one.
- No. It's for my mother, it's her
A lot of these days,
huh, Juanito?
- Miguel.
- What?
Stay near the car tonight.
In case we need to get out of here
- Yes, sir.
- 12 pesos, sir.
Thanks.
- Wait. Your reciept.
- Don't worry about it.
Open up, it's me.
- Hungry?
- It's the wedding feast.
- Don't talk to any strangers.
- I don't know any strangers.
Open up!
I'm listening to you eat.
Sound likes its good.
- What do you do when you're hungry?
- Eat?
- Take some.
- Thanks.
And when I'm thirsty?
- There's a glass over there.
What's your name?
I mean, you're real name.
Why the hell do you want
to know my name?
I bet you're from Kansas or Missouri.
Where are you from?
Here and there.
My favorite place.
That's where I'm from too.
- I was just going to turn off the light.
- I was going to too.
By shooting it?
Good night to you too.
Who is it?
Miguel.
Sir, they're coming.
They're here.
Richard?
Yes.
Is the car outside?
Yes, sir.
Go out through the window. We'll pass
everything to you. Hurry.
Where's Felipe?
Right here.
Thanks.
What are you doing?
I can't go out like this.
Are you crazy? Come on.
We were so close.
If Miguel doesn't get back before
Richard does, you'll see.
He's going to try to con fuse him, isn't
he?
But, what if it doesn't work?
Then we'll be in a big mess.
Hide!
Good afternoon,
Mr. And Mrs. McClan.
I still can't believe it.
You've got a lot of class.
When you believe it
you got it.
You must have traveled with better
company
What do you
mean by good company?
All my life I've ridden a horse between 2
countries.
That's what I figured. I guess
we can share some of our in formation
Like what?
Like, who Harvey's connections are.
Where to get the merchandise,
who it is given to.
I forgot to tell you,
I also know how to keep quiet in two
Be careful!
Move your cart so we can get through.
Hey man!
It's blocking the road.
Quick!
Hurry!
We were almost there and
now all this is going to hold us up.
He's knows more than you think.
She's a good gal, McClan, even though
she isn't so smart sticking around with
I wouldn't say the same about her,
Richard.
I hope you don't
have a reason to live.
Well, I can think of at least 3.
I told you you're luck would change.
Look, maybe we could make a deal.
A deal?
Nobody can say that
I didn't make you laugh.
Quiet! What's this?
It's on fire!
Help me! The horses!
Help!
Get the car.
Can't you go any faster?
I would if I could.
Don't tell me that Miguel
went back to sleep.
He's not sleeping.
Aren't you going to stop?
Not while I still have gas.
Do you have a cigarette?
Sorry for the trip I'm giving you.
Since we have the drugs and the body in
the car, all we need now is the police.
They're getting closer quickly.
Why are you stopping?
Have you ever tried to con fuse one of...
those Mexican police?
It's impossible.
What's the emergency man?
We have an ill man with us.
We need a doctor, quick!
Follow me.
What?
And they told me that you weren't that
smart.
If I was, I would be working
in the factory with my dad.
A dead end.
What happened?
Get up.
Hi, Jose, how are you?
Good, man.
Come with me.
I lost two Americans around here.
Hurry, let's go,
come on.
Don't go man.
Have you seen two Americans come
through here?
Stop!
We got lost. Please, hurry,
this man is really ill.
His stomach hurts.
We found him on the road.
Doctor!
Follow me. Don't get lost.
Ok.
I want some more beer.
This man isn't
ill, he's drunk.
Drunk?
Let's go.
I thought he was sick.
Your tourist visa, sir.
Yes, of course.
Mr. And Mrs. John "McClein.
McClan."
Yes. We're on our honeymoon.
Newlyweds.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Have a good honeymoon.
Bye
Bye.
Love is beautiful no matter where you
are.
They will look for us if they find Miguel's
body.
Good, are you ready?
Yes?
Give me a hand.
I can't do it myself.
There it goes!
Good.
That's it. Let's go.
"Airport. 10 km." Let's go.
How many miles are 10 km?
Do you know the conversion?
Yeah.
10 km is about 6 or 7 miles.
I knew I'd be happy with
a smart guy like you. 7 miles.
It can't be more than 5 and a half now.
Five and a half! Why didn't you
crash the car a little closer to the
Let's sit down.
Someone will pass by soon.
Maybe they can take us.
With Big Ritchie.
What a great way to escape.
You're the one who picked it.
I know what I'm doing. Do you?
I'm running away.
You'll get tired, won't you?
No.
How long have you been doing this?
Let's see, I started in nursery school
So, it's been a while now. What about
you?
I was destined to be a criminal when
I was 7 or 8.
I learned everything so
I wouldn't be conned. I got into this
I met Harvey and
I've been with him ever since.
Get your stuff, quick!
He was in a hurry.
What happened after nursery school?
When I was a teenager, I ran away
and a month later I met Rocky.
Who's Rocky?
The only man I've ever kissed.
I felt so bad seeing him hanging there
over the cold cement, dead.
What happened to him?
I shot him.
I promised I'd never go back
to kissing girls.
Does that answer your question?
Someone's coming.
Good morning. Where are you going?
To the airport, our car stalled.
Do you speak English?
Yes, why?
I don't understand your Spanish
that well.
We are trying to get to the airport.
The bus didn't stop to pick us up.
This is Tomas. He's always in a hurry.
Get in.
Thanks.
I'll sit here.
Can we go?
Si, I mean, "yes"
I was a teacher for 3 years
and I was a water inspector.
Now I own 40 acres
of land and have 12 kids.
12 kids?
That's a lot of acres!
That's very interesting, but is there
an airline that crosses over the border?
No, but don't worry. I'll take care of
everything. I'm an important man.
I have a friend. A pilot.
Does he have his own plane?
A little one.
Do you have money?
Yes, a little, just a little.
Ok. Good.
Why are we stopping?
Yes, sir. I have a phone.
I'm going to call Pablo at the airport.
Thanks.
I'll be right back.
I hope no one is keeping an eye on the
airpot.
You're right.
My dad welcomes you.
Thanks.
Hi!
You should be fumigated!
This woman has no idea.
About modern advancements.
Give it to me. I can hear better.
You're driving me crazy.
Hello!
My wife. She butts into everything.
I understand.
Look!
What a nice clothesline.
It's not a clothesline.
It's a telephone cable.
I can't hear you, Pablo. Talk louder.
They're welcome here.
Pablitio is one the phone
if you want to talk to him.
Thanks.
Hi Pablito.
That's fine, Pablito. Good.
We're going to pay him 75 dollars.
Ok.
I'll take them.
OK.
What's this?
This?
One more thing, sir.
I'm also the oldest alguacil.
That's like a "sheriff", right?
Yes, I'm an important man.
Yes, you are.
But not a very modest one.
That's all right. Excuse me.
Hello?
Let me talk. I can hear better.
She does everything better.
I'm going to fix the line. I'll be back
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Tell Portillo to go to the
airport right away.
Hello?
It's the police.
I'm going to take my clothes off the line.
Hello? What did you say?
Yes, we can hear better.
Hello?
Portillo is fixing the wire.
Hurry up. I need to use the phone.
And he should keep an eye out for two
murderers
Yes, I'll tell him. Bye.
Did you get the message?
There are two criminals around
suspected of murderer.
No.
You have to get to the airport
and make sure they don't escape.
Of course, but
who am I looking for?
I'm calling the police.
I have a description.
It's a man and a woman. The man is
tall, elegant and well dressed...
with dark hair and good manners.
Yes.
And the woman is short,
with a pointy nose, brown skin...
and a green glass eye.
Right. They can't escape Portillo.
We've got to hurry.
We have to get to the airport.
Bye.
Bye, sweety.
What are you waiting for?
This is it.
Let's go!
When are we leaving, Pablito?
In a second, sir.
What happened to the sheriff?
He's still searching the entrance.
Looking for a fat, short,
woman with long hair.
Don't be offended.
What is Pablito doing?
Trying to jinx our luck?
We would be better off if the police
didn't rush our friend.
They've cut all the
telephone lines.
We can leave whenever you want.
I guess our next
stop will be after the border.
Yes, the border.
The parrot can come with me,
OK
Portillo told me that
you have to get back to work right
Right?
Yes.
Portillo told me that
you like birds.
Yes.
How long have you been married?
3 weeks.
5 weeks.
Newlyweds should talk more.
We're trying, right honey?
What's going on?
Look what he's doing, eating.
What's wrong with that?
Do you think he'll give me some? I'm
Again?
You just ate last night.
We're out of gas.
Gas?
We're out in one tank.
I'm going to check the other one.
I thought you filled them both.
Don't worry.
Great. What do we do now?
I'll land on the beach.
You can't land on the beach.
Isn't the sand too soft?
It's not too soft for me.
Better?
I feel weak.
Excuse me, sir
can you help me please?
Don't go anywhere.
How long will it take to fill them?
10 minutes.
Can you do it in 5?
Yes.
But, we'll have to clear
some of the sand before we take off.
Do we have to wait until dark?
Not tonight.
It's too dark. We'll do it tomorrow.
Tomorrow?
What are we going to do about food?
That's a problem.
All I have is a pack of cereal.
What flavor?
Something good.
Why don't you sit down and take it easy.
Dinner will take a while.
Ham and eggs, and
tomorrow hot biscuits and lots of coffee.
Are you ok?
It's nothing. I like to dream.
Is there a motel in Ensenada?
One for tourists.
Isn't that what we are?
Want me to tell you something?
No, I'll tell you.
We're a bunch of idiots.
With a thousand policemen chasing us.
And my friends from the south
and our fish dinner.
Who made the bet?
You know, you're a smart girl.
Sometimes I have a feeling...
that you haven't told me everyting.
You know what? I have that same
I don't think you
learned to fish in jail.
I learned to fish in school.
My father used to take me
fishing on Sundays.
A few days ago
I would have believed you.
Why don't you tonight?
I don't know.
You seem like the hardened type.
But not so much now.
I believed a few things
about you too that I don't now.
Good morning. Welcome.
It's beautiful!
I told you.
I didn't think you knew about these kinds
of places.
What made you so clever, Johnny?
This way please.
Can I take your bags
to your room, sir?
No, leave them here.
Thank you, Mr. Jackson.
Mr. Jackson?
I'm like a phone book.
I must be going crazy.
That makes two of us.
It's a beautiful room
For 125 bucks it should be.
How long are we staying?
We'll cross the border tomorrow.
Do you have a plan?
The Gambin Plan.
We'll leave
the box with them and go.
They'll ask us to pay tax.
We'll refuse, they'll insist and we'll leave
What about the bird cage?
Won't it be a problem?
No. It's against the
law to take birds over the border.
We'll argue with them, take the
cage, and leave the bird.
They'll insist and you'll refuse.
Not me. I never argue.
Do we have to leave tomorrow?
Yes. I have to...
I'll see you downstairs, at the bar.
Thank you.
A pack of cigarettes, please.
And a few of these cigars.
Thank you.
Hello Alonso
Hello Johnny.
Do you have the police under control?
We would, if it weren't for a few
gringos' who never
take a break from being stupid al the
Is Big Richard following me?
Yes, he's in the city.
In the city? That's good.
I'll try to get him to cross the border.
What's going on with Harvey Gambin?
Get ready to grab him.
I think we know
everything we need to about our Mr.
Good.
Who's the girl with you?
She used to work for Richard. We're on
the
I'm going to leave her at the border.
I hope it goes well.
You know it's illegal to carry drugs
even for an officer of the law, right?
I know,
but you have to take risks.
Do you want a key to my room?
I already have one.
Hello?
I want to place a call...
to the US border agents.
Hello?
Yes, I'll connect you.
Mr. Peterson.
It's for you.
It's McEvoy calling from Ensenada.
This is Peterson.
I'll call narcotics in
Los Angeles.
What should I do with the girl?
Leave her there, detained.
I'll go by myself to Los Angels.
What's up man?
You look nice.
Thanks.
Let's sit at a table.
I ordered you a daiquiri.
How did you know?
I like your dress.
It looks very nice on you.
It's a costume.
It could very useful fro you.
You shouldn't
drink out of such a short straw.
I'll be careful.
I didn't know you were a musician.
Like the one in "Martini"
You're full of surprises.
I am.
That's me.
Where are you going?
I'm going to look for the car.
I want to see something.
Now? I thought...
Richard is in the city.
We should cross the border.
Stay here until I get back.
McClan.
I wouldn't do it. Go on.
Where?
Try going towards the elevator.
You're doing great.
What floor?
Third.
Are you enjoying your stay?
It's wonderful.
Open up.
I'll get it.
You're under arrest, Richard.
You're very kind.
Did you fall from a tree?
Now, he's playing that he's a cop.
Hands up.
Up, now!
He has another one in the sling.
He's a cop.
That's what the badge says.
I've had a thousand chances
to kill you, dirty, sell out cop.
Is this your gun?
Yes.
Take them out the back door.
Walk.
Thank you for having
acted like true gansters.
In the name of the Mexican government
of Baja California, you're welcome.
How long will it take to get to Tijuana?
About 2 hours.
Good Bye!
Bye!
Johnny!
Johnny, over here! I bought you this.
In case you have walk home.
Thank you.
No.
I guessed you wore a 4 but...
I thought you'd be more comfortable in a
6.
Thanks Johnny.
Ok.
The gardenias are fresh.
Flowers!
For the woman?
Thanks
They're for the misses.
The misses will put them in a book
and save them forever.
You should hold on to them
untill we reach the border.
She's also keeping the flowers?
We'll be there in 10 minutes.
10 minutes.
In 10 minutes we're going to lose a lot.
Where were you born?
Missouri.
And you?
Anything to declare?
Not much.
A few things.
Leave your car here and take whatever...
you have to declare to the office.
How's your trip?
Pretty good.
Very nice.
Husband and wife?
Yes.
Then, there's just one form.
I'll fill it out.
Declare what you brought from Mexico.
If you were there 24 hrs you
can spend up to 100 dollars each.
Then, sign here.
Mrs. McClan, can we talk?
Of course.
This way, please.
You're under arrest.
What?
I'm being arrested?
Yes.
No, you've made a mistake.
My name is Haley. The Los Angeles
police department has a...
file about me as well as
the narcotics department.
I'm sure about this.
I'm sorry.
I suggest you cooperate
with the authorities.
It will be much easier for you.
You're suggesting that I cooperate?
The charges are possesion of
narcotics with the intent to contraband
You don't believe him, do you?
Of course I do.
He's a policeman.
A policeman.
Are you a policeman?
I am, I work for customs.
Great, you've shown me your manliness
and shocked me with flowers.
What a show! Do you have a badge?
Yes.
They whole time, you were going to
Well, you've certainly done it.
My work isn't always this easy.
There are a few things harder
than playing the role of a stickler.
Keep talking. You're killing me.
Hello, Peterson.
You must be McEvoy.
I'm Whitaker.
How are you?
You don't care if
we use your office?
What happened to Gambin? Hi Haley.
Sir, I have to tell you something.
Tell me later.
Good, McEvoy.
Wait, sir. Do you know her?
Of course, she's...
What are you doing here?
I'm under arrest.
For what?
Contrabanding drugs.
Would you like to explain this to me
miss?
But, what happened to Richard?
She knows all about Richard.
And how do you know that she knows?
I'm the one who found her and had her
Richard is looking for other
unk owing people for his Mexican
Wait a minute.
It's very simple.
I brought this man to the
border so that he could be arrested.
That's not true. I brought her.
What do you mean?
Do you mean
you've been watching her?
Yes. She's one of Richard's girls.
I thought she'd give us in formation.
And you were watching him?
Yeah, I didn't know who he was.
When I got to Mexico
for the Richard case, I found him.
Wait a minute.
Let me put this all in order.
Who is this girl?
She's Madelaine Haley from
the Los Angeles police.
Imagine that.
This explains a lot.
Of course it does.
You're a very smart agent.
Mr. Whatever your name is.
Thank you. You're also very bright
Ms. Haley.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
So, we've taken care of that.
What happened to Gambin?
We have to get in touch with
his contact at the zoo tomorrow.
Mr. Whitaker, I'd like
for you to take me off the case.
Don't be stupid.
Tomorrow, what time?
Noon.
And then what?
If it goes well, we can
get Gambin's strongest men.
This is great, McEvoy.
I'm going to leave the case, Mr.
Leave what? You're are the best
people for the job. Don't you think so,
She has the equipment
and has no doubts about using it.
The two of you work well
together. Be at the zoo tomorrow.
You'll go together and keep
working as a team.
Yes, sir.
Mr. Whitaker, I just...
An order is an order.
What time is it?
What?
I asked if you knew what time it was.
Yes sir.
1 minute to 12.
There aren't many people here today.
On the weekends you can't...
They look hungry.
They're always hungry. They eat like
horses. I give them horse meat.
This has been great...
Hello.
You both look surprised.
You didn't expect to find me here, huh?
I expected to meet whoever it was going
to be.
Exactly.
I'll pay both of you.
I'm not worried, Harvey, now
I know you're on both sides.
Yes my friend. The Californian and
Mexican syndicates are mine.
Some day you'll learn, Johnny,
that you can't trust anyone.
I know.
I've already learned.
Did you get the goods through
the border ok?
Yes.
They seem pretty innocent.
I've seen a lot like them at the border.
Come to my house as soon as you can.
628 Gown Drive, end of the street.
Let's go.
Come in McClan
Sorry I couldn't get here earlier.
This is McClan, boys.
Hello.
Did you have any problems?
Yes.
Take out the rest of the goods, Buddy.
All of it?
All of it.
Tonight we'll meet
our contacts.
McEnvoy has 70 seconds to leave.
I hope he makes good use of them.
You'll leave for Chicago in the morning.
They'll pick you up when you get there.
OK.
Harvey, before you go on...
can you split it up later?
Give me my part and I'll go.
I'll give it to you, Johnny.
Are you in a hurry?
No hurry.
You'll go to San Francisco.
What about Melvin?
I'm following the order of the list,
dummy.
What do you want to drink, McClan?
If we're going to be staying here
I'll eat something. Where's the kitchen?
There are sandwiches at the bar.
And what did you say about coffee?
I'll make you some in a second.
I'll do it?
The kitchen in on the other side.
Does anyone want coffee?
NO.
Just a second.
I'll get it.
The key is in my pocket.
Just a second.
This is a raid!
You're all under arrest!
Come out the main door
with your hands in the air.
Do you hear me, Gambin, McClan,
Cliver, Harry, Larridge?
Give me a hand.
They're not going to catch me with
evidence.
There's a box behind the bar.
We'll put it all in there.
Not even in your dreams, Gambin.
No one's hiding anything.
What are you doing?
I'm taking all this.
You're crazy.
I told you not to trust him.
They'll kill you
and all of us.
Get him over there!
Johnny!
It'll be better if you wait here.
Haley!
Yes, dear.
Are you ok, John? I guess so.
Where's Harvey?
Johnny, are you ok?
I've never felt better.
THE END.